welcome to wall street the epicenter of
financial power in america perhaps the
money capital of the world
the globally oriented financial firms
based here in the new york stock
exchange that operates here have
extraordinary influence on the politics
and policies of this country
no one has elected them and in fact
these financial firms are trying to undo
the regulations and new laws governing
them imposed by the congress
the people on wall street are just one
of a number of unelected and very
powerful forces that operate in the
shadows behind the scenes they're the
media uh forces uh they're the military
and industrial forces the corporate
forces and they're the forces that we'll
be investigating in this television
series which asks a question that most
of our media does not
who rules america
every four years americans go to the
polls to elect a president
it's a ritual that goes back to the
founding of the nation in 1776
our economy seemingly on the brink of
collapse
every four years politics and
politicians dominate our television
screens dominate our news and dominate
our national discourse
[Music]
i'm ron paul and i approve this message
while independent watchdogs call this
president president barack obama is
running for reelection
mitt romney stood with big oil for their
tax breaks attacking higher mileage
standards and renewables
he is attacking and being attacked by
republicans
he said he would turn this economy
around in three years or he'd be looking
at a one-term proposition we're here to
collect all right
the two parties may be fighting a
political war but pundits label it a
horse race fueled literally by billions
of dollars in campaign contributions
used for pervasive advertising
where one president's failed policies
really hit home
welcome to obamaville the focus is on
political personalities not the forces
they represent
a large industry of commentators and
pollsters are paid to tell us who's
ahead and who's behind
the focus invariably is on the
candidates not the issues but everyone
knows the campaigns are run behind the
scenes by professional strategists media
experts and political advisors then
there's going to be a one-term
proposition to me
the political ads are cynical and slick
almost every word is scripted
symbols trump substance slogans are
market tested aimed at promoting
perception and reinforcing prejudices
that a rude nation marketing is the
mission
selling is not telling
on one level this whole spectacle is
presented as a triumph of democracy as
if the candidate who wins will run the
country but being in office doesn't
necessarily mean being in power
americans believe they are determining
their future are they do most know or
are they ever told who rules america
i just think that these people are you
can't really see them
yeah that's what i think the people who
rule america people are behind the
screen they are behind screen
invisible
to the general public
and do you think people really know
what's going on
[Applause]
to some extent yes and to some extent no
to what extent yes to what extent though
about 50 50.
who rules america there's no one right
answer pulitzer prize-winning american
historian eric foner says it's a
question that raises many more questions
about power that works from the shadows
who rules america
uh you know there's no one single easily
defined group who rules america but i
think
you know
not just now but i think for a couple of
generations we have had a
what what the sociologist c wright mills
called in the 1950s a power elite an
interlocking set of connections of
people in business
in politics in the military
who
pretty much determine the parameters of
possible change it's not that they rule
america in a conspiratorial way and of
course there are elected officials but
the leeway of those officials is
constrained by what you might call the
permanent government
presidents come and go but there's a
kind of permanent establishment what you
know president eisenhower called the
military-industrial complex but now it's
more a military financial complex
that really you know determine as i say
determines the limits
we're at the left forum a gathering of
progressive intellectuals and scholars
and students held every year here in new
york city there are 1400 speakers this
year they don't agree on everything but
they do agree that america is not the
democracy it claims to be they all want
to know who rules america professor
stanley aranowitz writes about the
research of this man c wright mills who
a half century ago wrote about the
existence of a power elite that
activists today refer to as the one
percent the people who run things
his contribution
to understanding the nature of power in
america is in the first place to
identify three institutional orders that
really together form the power elite an
elite that is generally speaking
unresponsive to the people unresponsive
to democratic liberties and democratic
procedures and he said the three groups
were the corporate capitalist
institutions
the military
and the third one was the top layer
of the political
directorate he called them and they were
they are the national
uh leaders like the executive branch of
government not even congress he said
congress was in the middle levels of
power it doesn't really share
the decision to make war
the major economic policies and so on it
participates at some level but basically
it's out of power and he said that
really has undercut
the whole pretense of progressive
and of representative government
this may be why in recent surveys only
seven to nine percent of the american
people in both parties believe that the
congress the so-called people's house of
government is representative and capable
of solving the country's problems
if politicians are trapped in a
polarized and highly partisan stalemate
who does exercise the power to decide
what the country's priorities and
policies should be
we asked jk fowler an editor of the
mantle a political magazine
i think it's
extremely complicated i think there's
not one particular answer for it
i think that a lot of the
stuff going on in america right now it's
being led by money and money to interest
in washington in particular
but i think there's a bubbling movement
from the ground up as well that's
happening is there a ruling class in
america or is that
an outdated concept
oh i'm a strong believer that there's a
there's a class in particular
in particular in new york city where
but i don't think it's
they're not hidden away in some room
with aquarius deeds in mind it's it's
more
it's more structural there's certain
clubs they go to there's certain streets
they live on they're interacting with
one another more we put that question to
aaron crowl a 30 year old working class
mother from a small town in wisconsin
who is working two jobs while pursuing
her education
if i was to ask you like who runs
america who rules america
what what is your you know what what is
your perception of that
people that have the money to do so
you know um
you know people that that that have
the money and the the resources to send
a lobbyist to washington
you know
like nobody from my town could afford to
send a lobbyist you know and say hey
harley-davidson is
you know threatening
to move their plants to china unless you
know everybody takes pay cuts
you know and could literally shut our
town down you know we can't afford to
defend ourselves
do you feel
as an american citizen that you have
power
you know in our country do you feel as
if you have
the ability to get
your
dream achieved
i feel like it's slipping
away
i don't think i do
you know because it feels like the
closer and closer i would get to that
you know like just a dream for me is to
finish college
you know and take care of myself and
take care of my son
you know but
even that now you know and and i
understand like
most a lot of people in my position
aren't even able to get that far now
so if the citizens who are supposed to
be in charge don't feel they are who
does
what we found is that by and large it's
the wealthiest americans who call the
shots through unelected institutions
that drive agendas in their own
interests
there may be a cabal running things but
in the end the state and the system
merges argues canadian political analyst
leo panitch
i don't think there's an external force
controlling the american state the
american state is capitalist to its core
in the very way it's organized it
doesn't do it because there's too much
influence from wall street it does it
because it is structurally embedded with
wall street it doesn't do it because
there's too much influence from a
military-industrial conflict it does it
because the military-industrial complex
is inside the state it's funded by the
state is part of the state
sure there are people who conspire and
there's people who act in secret but
capitalism is not a conspiracy the
people who have the wealth they're not a
conspiracy we know who they are
we know how they collect this money they
take it out of our pocket they put it in
theirs and it's not a big mystery
there seems to be corporate forces in
addition to wall street that essentially
help guide our political and economic
direction
leading are america's top corporations
political analyst michael claire has
studied the political economy of oil for
20 years and says a lack of media
coverage keeps the public in the dark
does the media cover it
the media doesn't cover this for the
most part in fact the media is largely
in league because of the advertising
dollars that the oil and gas lobby
provides they're very heavily dependent
on advertising revenue so they're very
careful in what they say who are they
accountable to
are there laws really controlling and
regulating what they do
there are laws but they have been
written largely by their lobbyists to
favor them
so in fact
the laws for the most part are in their
favor not in the favor of most americans
is there an issue where we've seen this
very clearly where the interests of the
oil industry or the or the energy
industry is in conflict with the
interests of americans well i would give
an example that
the oil industry has been pushing for
drilling in the deep waters of the gulf
of mexico and off the coast of alaska
for example and they get all kinds of
tax benefits for that kind of deep water
drilling and they were able to do so
during the bush period with absolutely
no oversight whatsoever hence the deep
water horizon disaster
most americans experience the oil
industry in two places at the gas pump
where prices often rise because of
speculation not just supply and demand
and also through tv advertising that
paints this very profitable business in
the most positive of terms
i'm still here and so is bp we're
committed to the golf for everyone who
loves it and everyone who calls it home
that's good for our country's energy
security and our economy
[Music]
which brings us to another set of
corporations the media companies
jeff cohen has been in the media and
written books about its impact in
shaping how americans think about their
country and its system of power he says
media companies push propaganda for war
it's the same exact media
quoting the same exact experts that
pushed our country and the world into a
war with iraq
and we were told by these media oh we're
so sorry we didn't know you know we made
a mistake next time we'll be more
vigilant but here we are next time 10
years later and the same media are
blowing smoke about a weapons program in
iran that doesn't exist there was no
weapons of mass destruction in iraq
either
and so we're hearing uh it's it's like
you know when the war drums are beating
and i worked in mainstream television
news in this country during the run-up
to the iraq war
when the war drums are beating they
don't let you put on
opposing views we tried to get opposing
views that question the evidence the
intelligence that would justify an
attack on iraq but we were kicked off
the air
and now you're finding it's it's a
nightmare it's a nightmare that's
happening again at the same time jeff
most people who work in major media and
i of course did as well don't believe
this they don't buy this they feel like
they do have the freedom
to cover issues
and that the
networks are much more diverse in their
point of view than outsiders like you
and maybe now me would say well the the
way to
rebut that
fiction
is just to look at what happened in the
wake of the iraq invasion those of us
who questioned the evidence that they
were a weapons and mass destruction
threat we were totally right and most of
us got kicked out of the tv networks the
people who got it wrong have promoted up
so this idea of diversity and the
mainstream media or good journalism will
win out certainly hasn't been proven in
the last 10 years where the the
journalists who got it right
have been punished sanctioned or kicked
out of the media and the journalists who
got it wrong
most of them have more power today to
blow smoke at iran than they had even
when they were blowing smoke in iraq
those people the people who own
institutions are usually very conscious
of their power not just as individuals
but as part of a dominant class says
independent tv producer brian droulay
so there's a lot of talk here about
democrats and republicans should we vote
for the democrats we wrote to the
republicans there's a lot of talk about
you know the rich versus the 99
but it's it's kind of you know the the
there's a certain kind of amnesia about
the structure of our society that at one
point in this country at least had some
currency you know in the 30s and even in
the 60s you could talk about the working
class nobody talks about the working
class it's all about there's a middle
class and then there's the one percent
as if there's you know and i guess then
there's some you know poor blacks and
latinos or something right and i think
that that word has been sanitized and
scrubbed out of
the vocabulary of the people of the
united states including out of the
vocabulary of the left
now that's not the entire left but even
the people that use the word class don't
seem to have the ability to
to phrase it in a way that actually
means something to people
to talk about class is not to talk about
a conspiracy but a complex system that's
evolved over the years a system that is
stratified and uses campaign
contributions and lobbying to ensure
that the politicians do the bidding of
the companies
so these are the building blocks of the
analysis we'll explore in this series on
who rules america
the argument is simple but hard for many
americans to comprehend because many of
us want to believe the myths we learned
in school that make us feel superior to
other countries and other peoples this
has been called american exceptionalism
many in america believe that god created
this country as the greatest country on
earth and that's what makes it so
special
you really have to start with that as a
basis for how the united states was
founded
roxanne dunbar ortiz is one leader of
america's indigenous people the first
americans they were the ones
to be eliminated
because it was their land that was
wanted not even their labor like in
latin america
the indigenous people were enslaved and
made into
peasants
but in north america the
anglo-anglo-colonialism in canada
it's not just that they weren't included
they were to be eliminated
and so questions about the custodians of
real power and who rules america lead
back to debates on how to remake power
how to challenge its distribution and
make it more transparent and accountable
these are the issues that the occupy
wall street movement is raising as it
challenges institutional power in an
attempt to revive grassroots democracy
david degraw explains occupy's origins
i mean it was like such a confluence of
events you know everything was moving in
this direction you know i was i was
looking around the world you know there
was there was protests happening in
egypt and then it moved to you know the
arab spring tunisia
and
all throughout europe came back and it
was just a matter of time before it hit
the united states
and really if you look the the
occupations globally
you know they became like the thing to
do so it was just a natural progression
for it to show up here i feel like it
shows up here because you know even
though
wealth is so concentrated you know the
people have a media system where they're
so propagandized
and they feel isolated but you know
occupy shows that people are you know
not suffering alone they're coming out
and
raising awareness and we change the
national discourse the movement is up
against powerful forces with large
budgets and the backing of police forces
and the political establishment
while these activists are on the front
lines of the fight for a people-ruled
america many of its people share the
same hope
you have a sense of class being
important in this country that they're
being like an upper class oh god working
class absolutely
absolutely um
you know i i'm a waitress at a very nice
restaurant and it's very clear to me you
know
where
what my role is and who i am you know
and you can tell just just from the
dialogue that i have with people you
know um
recently i had i talked to a general
manager of a fairly large business in
our town and
you know when when i mentioned that i
was going to a public school you know
i got kind of an eye roll and oh yeah my
tax dollars pay for that you know and
it's
so you feel like there's all this
resentment
against working people kind of feeling
like they don't deserve what they're
what little they're getting absolutely
absolutely and especially you know with
with the recent attacks on public sector
employees like on on teachers and you
know people are saying you know they
don't deserve those benefits we all
don't get those benefits so
so they don't deserve them either you
know or like why is it the conversation
maybe we should all work to get those
for everyone instead of taking it away
from the few that do have them
you know when when i hear you talking
uh
you know i realize there's a
such a bigger picture here that most
people even understand
that we have
you know a country where
the dream is slipping away
for so many people
and they don't feel
particularly powerful they don't feel
like they can do anything they can
achieve anything they can make a
difference right
well
i think
the dream has shifted to
hopefully i wake up tomorrow and i'll be
able to pay my rent and keep a roof over
my head you know or it's just like
you know i'll i'll work on achieving my
dream tomorrow but today
you know i have to
i have to go to class you know and i
have to you know i have to get my work
done i have to go to work and i have to
try to squeeze a couple hours of sleep
in and then
you know and
it's
now you're here at this conference with
all these brilliant
theoreticians and analysts and
professors and experts and leaders
and
how do you feel about this this idea
that people have to get together to make
a difference
i think it's wonderful
i am
i feel so blessed to be able to be here
with people like that because
i want to learn you know somebody had
you know had said to me why don't you
leave where you are and i don't think
that's the answer i think
that it's my job
as somebody who cares about these things
to learn from these people to learn from
these brilliant minds and so i can take
this back
to people and and and
and show them and explain to them where
we don't have access to this kind of
thing every day you know and
to hopefully try to enlighten them a
little bit
aaron expresses the hopes of many
ordinary americans who want to reshape
the nature of power so that the 99
percent not just the one percent can
rule but as you can see in here it's not
a battle she feels she is winning
perhaps that's why she like many want to
know who rules america
coming up in the next episode of who
rules america how the history of
conflict between the 99
and the one percent goes back to the
american revolution
the degree of inequality
never before has the very very top the
one percent had so much of the national
income and wealth in its own hands
next time on who rules america